- New in theaters this weekend, Joker.
What will you see?
This is your weekend ticket.
(calm percussive music)
- [Joker] My mother always tells me.
To smile, and put on a happy face.
She told me I had a purpose.
To bring laughter and joy to the world.
Hey!
Stop them!
(ominous music)
Is it just me,
or is it getting crazier out there?
- At last, Joker hits
theaters this weekend.
In this standalone origin story,
Joaquin Phoenix plays Arthur Fleck,
a man who is beaten down, mocked,
and is never taken seriously.
As society continues to wear
on him, he starts to crack
and see the whole world
as being one big joke.
And it isn't long before
he completely breaks,
and he himself becomes a joker.
(Joker laughing)
The film is to be a version of the Joker
we haven't seen on the big
screen, and will launch DC Black,
a whole different universe
of comic book inspired films,
with a much darker and serious tone.
This movie's for you
if you're down for a grim
and gritty origin story,
you wanna see the film that got an
eight minute standing ovation
at the Venice Film Festival,
or you're gonna be that guy
and dress as Joker for Halloween.
I'm going as Harley Quinn, so.
That is your weekend ticket.
What will you see?
And check back next week to
see who's a better actor,
Will Smith, or Will Smith.
Who's the second guy?